it's yes three-point make ain't good
defense
Finch Carter takes white how about that
[Applause]
they with Real Madrid we're coming to
the States
three seconds remain in the quarter
Carter yeah
[Applause]
sets up harder
your absence
just make it probably coincide cable
backward learners from the he was
convinced complex started oh and
seventeen high/low Carter took the job
with no gray hair
this will not go away Carter top the
high glass
through jury against Tenace Vince fakes
just be long
[Applause]
and finish the beautiful 12:7 Cole
coming over from Miami played his
college ball at quiz bin' state [ __ ]
Tyler with a pull-up Britons without
[Applause]
double
here on the floor so who is going to get
him into the set now of Mike Conley
[Music]
[Applause]
with this lineup but we haven't seen
this much as Vince Carter takes that
contact able to get that one through the
defensive end of the floor and
offensively outside he holds takes two
three
[Applause]
Vince just great patients out there
Kevin the pump-fake saw the disease
shots in the face Vince Carter quit mr.
creeply outside is kept alive insanity
smaller guys have played together longer
and they understand what they're trying
to get accomplished harder off the bench
with a hoop and the harm
convinced with six points last night
against Houston it's only kidney
knockdown long-range shots but here does
a good job putting it on the floor feels
the contact at time go right to the
basket misfire tap out rebound
[Applause]
the naked eye I thought he got it off in
time
and sure enough he did
[Applause]
Zach Randolph let's do it himself
Chalmers on the pitch out Vince for
three tango and a timeout taken by Bret
round
[Applause]
the show the gold the finish
Chalmers with the steel keeps it in
playing
[Applause]
Mario game team is there running up
there going the other way
and mythos continues to make the page
production from the Grizzlies has been
fantastic tonight and bits Carter bin
Saturday rev it up to the after the
Grizzlies that's pretty
after the Grizz shot clock down to seven
to Michael Green
then he just makes right here good thing
he's the reverse lab oh no
no this is the old Vince part Linsanity
is in the building again he likes to
throw back threads Vince
[Applause]
with the last shot here Vince
[Applause]
whoo putting his busy team going into
the 16 at the brain they have pulled
within five because he did it at 41
years of age he played all 82 so I don't
think it's too much to ask guys to
actually come to work and thought about
it shot clock down to five Randolph
calling for it Harrison stuck in a
corner bullet pass Vince Carter a three
offensive end deflections have been
paramount and then here terrific pass in
Vince before the clock goes that Denver
has the lead late here in the first
quarter Carter around the Randolph
screen
Vince pulls up a hips another Drive
going towards the basket with Vincent
Vince Carter here many people partners
can off the dribble wait to the rack of
the Nuggets are back up by four and a
Memphis timeout coming here perhaps
Vince Carter with the mate so long two
Randolph against embiid
look Carter gonna cut in a slam
[Applause]
everybody thought it was going back says
that Randolph at the top of the key but
at the last minute
Harrison sees both streaking Vince
Carter who get Harrison against
Rodriguez bench steps out to three it's
true disrespect to him that's just not
his game Carter four threes Pango let's
me shots last night
[Applause]
right knock away by Zach Randolph to
stay involved in the defensive way and
the events carpenter has been making
miraculous shots he scores
[Music]
known as Air Canada I'm going to spin
I'm gonna spin again sensational by this
car turns the Atrus one and another
memory right
his wife tucker welcoming twin girls
earlier today carter for three its toll
that'll do it three that went too strong
to Michael Green offensive rebound
Vince will tee up a three Memphis Jim
Michael uncorks a three well short Vince
Carter yes as a past partner he saw that
Vince had the inside position to feature
Vince Carter Monroe that was rate free
by Mike Conley got three on one if they
hurry
Tony Allen to Michael Green Vince Carter
[Applause]
you see him great passing by this team
event said oh I still have hops off of
the bird
slapping the backboard afterwards
monster reverse reverse the Ducks not
the backboard for Laurie mentioned the
third quarter will tell the tale of how
far back this team is a lot of standing
right now partner will trap the three
Banco bailout triple by Vince Carter
rebound close to Koufos Carter's open
runs the floor and he has the basket so
Kings needed a easy basket
just to kind of break
Vince Carter with a howl the second time
finish their beautiful Passover from
Willie cauley-stein look at Carter again
[ __ ] party but it doesn't matter it's
Kings Bowl Carter
[Applause]
another looks Carter he's got 17
Sacramento with the lead Carter both
Donovan healed and coasted Cooper's
who's got the ball will set the lineup
for Denver when they touch Vince Carter
[Applause]
Martin trying the guard Cooper's inside
obviously a mismatch in there but you
don't need to go in there with Ben
sanity on track
[Applause]
oh those young legs now takes a deep
three then a three prevents Torian
Prince a lot of pressure on these
dribbling the double-team came right
there you see Vince Carter from downtown
New York knocks it down
Gibbs advance fires murder gets it back
to it
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the pantheon we have to get
him around the basket getting Hawkstone
working the ball around the woman this
kind of goes up no he didn't stick his
leg out actually plate ran into his nose
the Raptors on January the 10th or four
to the line for Lowry bits
Vince Carter with his 20 pointer makes
it 31 to seventeen point ballgame Trey
was six
Trey with five prey hands it over Carter
will fire a shot here by Vince Carter
and rhythm stray to the foul line backs
out Vince eggs and hits that's that's
amazing how at his age he can still do
those sort of things Carter a deep one
of all he's feeling it harder another
deep one Vince Carter putting on a show
here in the garden came into the league
is a real pest defensively two-time Big
East Defensive Player of the Year for
the Friars Carter on the bounce in Vince
three seconds to Vince goes to the hole
how you get it done if the end of the
quotas books I can get to the rack
between two defenders offices
here's Vince shot clock in single digits
great double behind the back defense
punk comes flying at him but that does
not matter
Vince Carter T Gibbs Carter three two
off the clock this one drops
he had [ __ ] QWERTY mates at Wake Forest
here's a lob defense what it's called on
the top this lobby look at these legs
nice little finger tip dunk 136 to 128
they got to give it to Vince he's going
to take a three hit it
136 to 128 they got to give it to Vince
he's gonna take a three
David the Knicks are applauding
[Applause]